hi guys and welcome back to City
skylines though today when it should be
much about the city at all
I wanna plan the rural area around the
city and kind of explain as I'm going
along this what exactly I'm doing and
why though I also do have to give a
quick disclaimer I am from like the most
urban area of the Netherlands and it's
very hard actually to find some good
information about rural planning so I'm
not I'm not entirely sure how accurate
this is going to be mostly it's going to
be based around my personal experience
some stuff that I've been able to find
on the internet but much of it just sort
of around the area that surrounds my
hometown I'm so yeah just so you know
and if anybody does have some good
insight on rural planning I would really
give you a hug if you could share it
that would be amazing
but even without that I think I'll be
able to at least do a decent job
simulating it I should probably already
start explaining what I want to do
exactly for those of you who aren't
Dutch you have no idea what I'm talking
about basically the rural type of area
that I'm gonna go for here is very much
agricultural and basically rural areas
in the Netherlands are quite similar to
what you've obviously are probably seen
quite a lot in City skylines small roads
with some houses attached to it and
different types of farms everywhere but
one big difference would probably be
valid very rectangular and not
rectangular per se in an entirely grid
like fashion but really stretched out
rectangles in different directions
everywhere which I believe to be is sort
of related to how the Netherlands is
pretty much built from Potter's or at
least the entirety of Holland is where
the the the very fact that the land
exists from porter's sort of not only
gives shape to the way the farmland
looks but also to what's actually formed
and that's something that I should
probably explain a bit more as one of
the Commons are killing the last video
pointed out which was actually very
helpful basically since the Netherlands
is Bill
we see level it needs the dykes to also
defend it from the rivers since the land
is also lower than the rivers and
because of this the land is very fertile
but also it's quite a big risk to grow
stuff outside of the dikes and usually
what's done is to have your cattle
outside the dikes and within the dikes
grow a lot of stuff and that's how I
think the Netherlands is also the second
biggest agricultural exporter of the
world but don't don't quote me on that
but yeah anyway that's why I wanted to
make sure that I would have really crops
over here in all of these rectangles and
filled in like that but one of the
important things which I should probably
note when it comes to the layouts is
that while I want to simulate the crops
and the shape of the rural areas with
all of these rectangles over here a very
key difference that you'll probably have
noted by now is that I'm not using any
ditches and I'm not using any small
canals or anything like that and that's
a bit of an issue and really just
something that I don't have because of a
game limitation I've tried a number of
dishes that were in the workshop as
placeable
assets and I wasn't really happy about
any of them and the in-game water system
just isn't good enough for ditches and
it would require tremendous effort to
even get it to work a decent way so in
the end I decided that I would just
settle on the pedestrian paths and place
those everywhere to divide the land up
in these rectangles which would normally
be done by ditches but sort of from an
aerial perspective I suppose the paths
at least do a decent job demarcating all
the different areas and that's basically
what I want to have that over there
you'll notice a couple of other
pedestrian paths over here especially
alongside the road but also underneath
the dyke over there which I basically
wanted to do as planned bicycle paths
and this is something that's throughout
the city at the moment and I've laid out
a lot of pedestrian paths that sort of
don't make any sense as pedestrian paths
but I've planned as bicycle paths I I'm
just a lazy bum and I haven't downloaded
after dark yet so I don't have access to
bicycle parts yet but um as soon as I do
which should happen in the future
hopefully I'll convert I'll convert
those to bicycle parts hopefully if
their work in any case that's why I'm
planning with all of those things and a
couple of things then I should probably
talk about in the overall planning of
this area like the overall sort of plan
is divide the land up into different
rectangles everywhere get some tree
lines here and there and different types
of quote unquote crops in different
rectangles even though it's kind of hard
to simulate that so basically I want to
do that with different bushes assets but
also the terraforming tool to place
different types of resources like or and
farming land to make sure that the
ground gets a different color yeah aside
from that I also want to get some small
towns in here and there some windmills
though again windmills is a bit of a
tough thing because in real life
windmills would be placed alongside
ditches because many of them are used to
pump water up into the river so I can't
realistically really get those in so
most of the windmills that I'll be
getting are just other types of
windmills but that means I can't spam
windmills in one big row like you would
often see them in the Netherlands also
what I probably want to get in here and
there is dikes even if they aren't
completely functional and I don't really
need them I should divide the Potter up
into different types of potters and kind
of make sure that if things flood
there's always a dike in the middle that
can save a different area once one area
floods so I'm going to want to have some
dykes here in there not to mention that
they've got quite a good aesthetic
appeal to making this area look a little
bit more Dutch especially since and this
is one of my issues with the map that
make it harder to add ditches but also
to make this area look a touch in
general there's a very slight hill going
on in the entire map basically there are
very slight Hills everywhere and it
isn't too big of an issue placing
anything or anything but it does make
I'm looking this make this it does make
in this rural area look touch quite a
lot harder since one of the key elements
really of the rural landscape in Holland
is that it's so awkwardly flat and that
is something that is gonna be hard to
convey with this very slight
terraforming going on with this map and
it also makes placing ditches a little
bit harder I tried to actually make a
ditch over here but really filled
because I forgot how the water system
works in this game and it just
eventually evaporated so if ever I want
to mess around with ditches a bit more I
should either try and get some new
assets that I might find the off tried
pretty much all the canal and ditches
assets out there and they all don't
really fit the rural feel I think so
it's I'm really gonna have to get water
out of the river if I ever get into that
type of thing yeah that's pretty much it
for the rural area the entire planning
probably some other stuff that I also
want to get in there is modern windmills
it's not just the traditional windmills
but really just some good old green
energy windmills here in there too as
long as it's far away from actual houses
that should be fine and also make the
area look a little bit more Dutch
because especially in the middle of the
Netherlands it's quite a common sight to
have windmills everywhere in rural areas
now but yeah that's my general planning
and I'm definitely up to changing some
different things and definitely up to
feedback about how it looks and whether
there's some things I might want improve
on it but that's the general sort of way
that I would go around it and over here
I just took a small break because I
figured I wanted to remove that part
with the houses over there since it was
just awkwardly close to the business
districts and a couple of supermarkets
would be a little bit better oh and I
wanted to demarcate this more area over
here for a possible future row house
area which is also why I wanted to add a
hill between this and the highway to
sort of act as a sound barrier without
having to have those ugly sound barriers
that come right next to your highway
because more often than not especially
with modern districts you see these
grassy hill highways sound barriers
because that's
just what people like a little bit more
and in terms of landfill you it
shouldn't be a problem
oh and especially these parts by the way
are where I was figuring that I would
have bicycle parts in the future because
basically and then in the Netherlands
bicycle parts are usually not attached
to the roads unless the roads are order
and they didn't add bicycle parts to
them yet there's always a small green
zone between the bicycle path and the
road which is what I sort of wanted to
imitate with these bicycle parts going
all along these roads over here but yeah
they are pedestrian paths at the moment
and I still have to convert them at some
point in the future once I actually
decide to spend some money and throw
some of it to Paradox Interactive Oh any
quick thing that always sort of annoyed
me about the highway system or on the
road system in this game in general is
how you always get these bridges and not
actual smooth ramps once you start
making some bridges over and over
another area like if you if you raise
the road as soon as you reach nine
meters or higher you get a bridge rather
than a hill with a road on top of it and
I really wanted to get this he will sort
of look to my flyovers and bridges and
ramps pretty much which is why I wanted
to take a bit of effort and make sure
that all of these roads who can actually
be supported by actual ground and not
just pillows though I also have to say
this is a bit of a boring interchange
and it's something that I'm just not
going to really find a way around since
I want to make sure that the highway
system is realistically convincingly
Dutch and especially for this size of
the city I just can't realistically get
any interesting highway intersections
going as much as I am a fan of highway
porn as well it's just something that I
can't really mess with for this city and
I want to keep it realistically simple
which means for the Netherlands that
pretty much all of my three-way highway
intersections are going to be trumpet
interchanges and the four-way
intersections are going to most likely
be a
exterior of cloverleaf interchanges and
turbine interchanges because that's
really the most common thing that you
often see and aside from that I want to
get a airport in the future so that
would be a good opportunity to get some
more interesting highway layouts going
but really that's still probably far
away in the future and I'm not quite
sure what I'm gonna do with that exactly
now over here I wanted to have a small
town it it currently has the name Apple
dam which is probably something that I
should get to I'm one of the worst
people in the world when it comes to
naming like I absolutely suck at naming
so this town over here I decided it
would be called the merry town of Apple
dam and but I don't know if that's
really a good name so if anybody does
have some naming suggestions I really
can't say that I'm gonna take any and
definitely can't promise anything but if
you do have some awesome suggestions and
you think you've got an amazing name
then don't be afraid to shout it because
it would be cool to have some names for
little districts and I'm not always the
best at coming up with names but yeah
Apple dam over here it's at least a good
way to reference something it's just a
very stereotypical kind of small rural
town I really wanted to get this rural
area to be a like a juxtaposition to the
city but not just in a way that I really
wanted to have that contrast but also
the many urban areas in the Netherlands
do still have some green fields between
all those cities and on purpose
leave a lot of farmland in the middle of
urban areas to make sure that not
everything becomes one enormous big
urban sprawl and I were to make sure
that I wouldn't get mad with this either
so yeah the entire rural area around the
city should just be a little bit more
romantic and natural and sort of a break
away from the concrete jungle and this
town would probably be a good example of
that and just a very small nice little
town I suppose in the middle of some
green fields I live in a Dutch type of
fashion with a church in the middle and
a windmill because how
don't have a windmill around it but yeah
that's pretty much the town of Apple
none nothing much is going on over here
just detached houses and that's about it
but I really wanted to have that in
there just to make the entire rural area
look a little bit more charming but yeah
again actually much of this area is
based on the area where I live and I do
realize that there are many different
ways in which rural areas are laid out
throughout the Netherlands and this is
really much just personal experience and
kind of based on my area in general and
that's sort of pretty much everywhere
from the random little towns to the way
that these farmlands are made and it
goes for just about everything except
for the city itself the city itself is
very all made ish for those of you who
are Dutch and probably know that city
yes very much like that and even though
I'm not too big of a fan of the way that
Almeida is as a city and I probably
wouldn't want to live there it looks
pretty cool from up in the sky and in
terms of city design especially for a
planned city I do kind of like it which
I incidentally one of my things that I
kind of like about planned cities in the
Netherlands is that they're not as
utopian or big in entire idea behind it
and they don't turn out like communistic
planned mega structures but still have a
bit of a town ish and a charming feel to
them which is basically what I want to
try with this city as well as much as
this city also is largely a planned city
anyway that's it for the real time part
but I still had a small hint that's of
the town I spot but I still had a more
real time part for the end of this video
so I'm gonna hand it over to my older
self here
all right so here's how the city looks
at the moment I just want to quickly go
over it and kind of explain what
everything is and what I want to do in
the future because it's kind of hard to
explain and see that in a time-lapse
basically the last thing I added over
here was the little town of Appleton oh
god don't pay any attention to the names
by the way I really suck at naming stuff
and I just wanted to come up with
something in a minute so I might change
this in the future
and if anybody has any good suggestions
feel free to just throw them out there
and I might take them but yeah basically
I kind of wanted to keep this little
town over here as a separate town from
the main city which is the general idea
that I want to go for for this entire
area which I'll get back to later but I
kind of want to sprawl some more small
towns around this area and sort of like
the first more old town out here with
just a simple Church some houses and a
windmill of course and this is the
general farming area this is also the
sort of style that I want to keep
throughout the remainder of the city
really I'm just not too sure if I want
to keep it as a crop I'm like at the
moment I have so many like crop fields
which is not that realistic I would love
to have some more cattle fields like
those very specific
well stereotypically touch almost cow
fields with just fields of grass
everywhere in very straights and great
like patterns with ditches in between
them where usually people just have cows
and stuff but it's something that I
don't think I can realistically get in
there not just because I can't really
get cows on fields I also don't think I
can get realistic touches I tried it
with a couple of them over here but as
you can see I don't think they really
look too great and they definitely don't
look too specifically touch and also
since this entire map has some very
slight Hills pretty much everywhere they
also start glitching on the side I'm
sorry about the terrible framerate by
the way there's not much I can do about
that
so yeah I'm not going to go with these
things don't really work in the end um
another thing which I should probably
say is that I try to have a little water
thing over here like it can out sort of
thing but I completely forgot that water
just disappears so I can't really use
this either unless I find a way to
connect it to the river but that would
just be way to complicate it not to
mention that and this is one big
limitation on getting farmlands to look
very Dutch realistically a little bit
over holland 101 the polos are below sea
levels so as soon as it rains or any
sort of water gets in you need to be
able to pump the water out and this is
what most of the ditches are for and
what actually most of the windmills are
for as well I used to raise the water a
little bit with each windmill so that
eventually you can raise the water
enough to get it out into the river and
make sure that the entire country
doesn't become sea again but the issue
is that I can't use water physics like
that in this game so functional
windmills are something that I can't
really have which makes placing a lot of
windmills and making things look touch
harder but it also makes actually having
Dutch looking ditches pretty much
impossible and now moving on though I've
got this little area over here I decided
that I wanted to make this entire thing
a little bit more open I think I also
want to remove a large part of the
forest over here is way too much foliage
ooh yeah I wanted to make this entire
area more open and make it more like a
office slash industry zone that's close
to the highway where a lot of traffic is
actually going with like your typical
IKEA and media markets and big more over
here I don't know what's up with the
garbage never had that before
I wonder how a parking lot can have a
garbage problem but yeah that's pretty
much what this area is for I think this
is actually my favorite part of the city
as stupid as it sounds this pretty much
came out the way that I wanted to make
it in the end and I'm quite happy about
the way that it looks to kind of have
that small industrial area just outside
the city with some shops and things like
that
moving from which this is just the
remainder of the city just the standard
houses I
remove the university over here in the
future and just make this entire area
one big Park and I don't know what I'll
do with this area over here to be quite
honest I was thinking I might turn it
into a more industrial type of zone
especially considering how close it is
to the highway but I might also place a
fence on top of this hill to make sure
that I can build a housing area that's
sort of sheltered from the highway over
here so I'm not quite sure what I want
to do with that yet I do now have some
sort of house neighbourhood in this
corner here and then over here I think
I'll have the train station which I do
want to make reasonably large I think
I'll just steal em sternums train
station because it's a Dutch looking one
and it works with two tracks I think
I'll go with that eventually and this
place would probably be best to have
some spawning areas realistically I
should have a large area with a number
of football fields and a couple of other
sports over here especially tennis is
probably quite important so I want to
reserve this area for some spawning
fields and then I might get some small
industry Lane over here not really do
much else with that and then eventually
I think this would be a good area to
have my football stadium which I
definitely want to have as well and then
I think over here I could have another
neighbourhood with houses but I'll sort
of have to think about that in the
future because I also want to have a
university and arguably the best place
for the university might be over here
but where exactly I want to place this
stadium University and housing area over
here I'm not quite sure yet so I might
just shuffle that entire plan around at
some point in the future other smaller
plans I have are fixing this
neighbourhood because right now one of
the big issues I think is that this is
very much a 70s cauliflower
neighbourhood even though it this
cauliflower neighbourhood itself needs
some fixing and then this is very early
20th century and this is very
reminiscent of the more recent
developments but
there is no real transition going on so
I think I just want to transform this
area I get rid of all the flat blocks
replace them with different types of row
houses and replace these two flats with
more modern flats I think to make this
area look more like a modern housing
area I can keep the cauliflower
neighborhood but I want I want to change
the shape a little bit just on the
outsides because realistically I would
kind of want the cauliflower
neighborhood to have a more round shape
and right now it's very like straight on
the edges over here but also over here
it has a very straight border around it
and I think by removing the houses over
here but also over here and especially
alongside the main road which I have
here and replacing them with parks it
should end up looking a little bit more
realistic than it does right now and
then I think I could make a small
cauliflower neighborhood over here too
and then at some point in the future I
should make the center of the city which
I'm not quite sure yet how exactly I
want to take away definitely not quite
sure about the layout yet but as you may
have noticed I moved these buildings
over here put them all in a row over
here and these are basically the
buildings which I think will be best to
make the center of the city with and
make it look reasonably touch but I'll
see you eventually how that's going to
work out I also want to put a wall
around it but the wall that I currently
have is this one but I'm not quite sure
how much I like it it's it's much more
reminiscent of a Mediterranean / France
yeah wall around the city and I don't
think I really kind of want to have that
type of look so I'll still look around
the workshop for other things that I can
use in that place but yeah that's pretty
much the city at the moment and then the
city is isn't going to grow too much
larger so it's just going to be this
little space over here and filling this
area in having some things over here but
that'll really be about it and aside
from this city I think I would like to
have a cool city over here just a
smaller one but that's all future
planning and to be quite honest my plan
at the moment for this entire map is to
just keep going until my computer can't
take it anymore
and my computer is already having some
troubles with it it took me a couple of
hours actually to get this thing to work
again and removed so many assets and
mods and tried so many different launch
that the settings but in the end it
turned out to be that my drivers
so I update updated those and now it
works again which is really great but I
do really fear especially with the fact
that I am using 8 of my 8 gigs of ram on
my computer that this entire map will
just fail at some point in the future
and if that ever happens I might start a
new one but hopefully it's not going to
happen anytime soon I just don't want to
think about it and I just want to keep
building on this map and sort of turn it
into an entire province and province and
just have some farms over here as well
some small towns here in there and fill
this entire area in in a way in which I
think I kind of want to do it I got rid
of all these forests which is going to
be pen I really want to do that but yeah
that's really about it so wonder what
alright make sense don't really know
what this is from but yeah that's what I
want to do with this area and that's
pretty could be about it so I think I'm
good to go for the next episodes I think
the next thing that I'm gonna start
doing is fill in this area with some
football fields and stuff like that and
have some houses or something else over
here and maybe start work on this area
with the train station and I'm still too
unsure about the center of the city to
really start doing stuff over there yeah
that'll be it
so thank you guys for watching and I'll
see you guys later